ce smartphone fait hyper peur à Samsung
cartoon avec son Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4
le smartphone a clapet et c'est
potentiellement aujourd'hui l'un des
smartphones qui cartonne le mieux chez
Samsung sauf que ce smartphone arrive et
il va faire vraiment mal il va être
vendu l'année prochaine en France en
2023 on va voir arriver le nouveau
smartphone 2 oppo c'est le oppo finden
de flip derrière ce qu'on va coucher
dehors arrive un smartphone extrêmement
bien rincé c'est le même format que le
Netflix 4 de Samsung avec un plus grand
écran extérieur on peut bien l'utiliser
pour regarder du contenu Tik Tok pour
faire du gaming pour répondre à des
messages bref c'est beaucoup plus
pratique que l'écran extérieur du
Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4 je trouve ça
vachement mieux d'ailleurs vous
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires